fentanyl is a synthetic opioid drug the
pharmaceutical form is prescribed to
treat severe pain usually from cancer or
after surgery
there's also an illicit form that's made
and sold illegally on the drug Market
people take it because it produces a
strong high and intense feelings of
well-being
its potency or strength is up to 50
times that of heroin an illegal opioid
and 100 times that of morphine another
opioid used to treat severe pain
as with any opioid fentanyl addiction is
a brain disease where you have an
overwhelming craving for the drug you
can't stop taking the drug despite the
harm it may cause you if you're addicted
and stop taking the drug you can feel
sick this sickness is called withdrawal
an important treatment for addiction to
opioids such as fentanyl is called
medication-assisted treatment or mat
matte is a whole patient approach that
combines medication to help you stop
using opioids with counseling and
behavioral therapy
three common medications used to treat
opioid addictions including fentanyl are
methadone buprenorphine and Naltrexone
in the brain each drug attaches to the
same receptors on cells as fentanyl does
methadone activates the receptors but
it's a slower acting drug than Fentanyl
because it takes longer to reach the
brain when used as prescribed
this reduces the high feeling and
prevents withdrawal symptoms
buprenorphine is a weaker drug than
fentanyl because it doesn't activate the
receptors is strongly this makes it much
less likely to cause an overdose than a
drug that fully activates the receptors
it also blocks fentanyl from attaching
to The receptors
as a result it reduces uncomfortable
cravings for fentanyl without making you
feel high
Naltrexone blocks the opioid receptors
by attaching to them so fentanyl can't
this prevents fentanyl from getting you
high it does reduce Cravings but does
not stop withdrawal symptoms
drug treatment is more effective when
combined with behavioral therapy
therapy can help you handle stress and
life events that can trigger cravings
for Fentanyl
a fentanyl overdose is a condition where
taking too much of the drug may cause
life-threatening symptoms
an overdose of fentanyl can slow or stop
your breathing
as a result the lack of oxygen can lead
to Coma permanent brain damage and even
death
call 9-1-1 immediately if you think of
fentanyl overdose has happened
start CPR if the person isn't breathing
or doesn't have a pulse
the most effective and life-saving
treatment for an overdose is naloxone
it's an injectable drug or nasal spray
that quickly blocks the effects of
Fentanyl and can stop an opioid related
overdose
for more information about treating
fentanyl addiction and overdose talk to
your health care practitioner